a staggering number of people are now
out of work in the United States a
result of the corona virus pandemic in
the past half hour the government's
revealed another 5.2 million have lost
their jobs in a week that takes the
total to at least 22 million in less
than a month and with many states
expected to extend orders to stay at
home hourly workers are really worried
about how they're going to pay their
bills
Natacha huname reports in Chicago if
there was ever a boom time in this
Chicago neighborhood no one living here
now remembers it the Cova 19 pandemic
has shattered the already precarious
lives of the many hourly workers in West
Humboldt Park I'm scared scared more of
a sense were like I don't know what's
gonna happen next I don't know what my
next move is gonna be less than two
weeks ago Jose Montoya was operating a
forklift and trying to save for an
emergency now a global coronavirus
emergency has arrived and like millions
of people
he's been furloughed indefinitely Montee
a joined hundreds of Chicagoans waiting
outside for several hours to get a
week's worth of donated groceries those
in line told me the money saved on food
must be used to pay for rent and
medicine Montoya says he could survive
without electricity or gas he's worried
about getting evicted from his apartment
and becoming homeless I gotta take it
day by day because if I don't then I'm
gonna lose my mind
okay a group of nuns and a priest the
size of a football team run the mission
of Our Lady of Angels food pantry where
the need has more than tripled the last
few weeks church services are canceled
unable to offer a smile or a pat on the
back to people seeking solace in crisis
they're trying to minister via phone and
email this is a time that the Lord has
provided for us to all reevaluate the
most important things in our lives and
to remember how grateful we should be
for our lives for the gift that God has
given us our lives our families our
friends the Greater Chicago Food
Depository distributes food to a network
of 700 pantries and programs in the
Chicago area spokesman Greg Trotter says
the pandemic is an unprecedented
challenge a third of their programs
aren't operating grocery store donations
have decreased and fewer volunteers are
showing up yet the demand is soaring
we're very concerned that this is a
longer this goes on the worse it's going
to be for our most vulnerable neighbors
back in West Humboldt Park
several Chicago Police Department SUVs
arrived with a drop in crime citywide
the officers loaded boxes of
non-perishable food into their vehicles
to deliver to the elderly and disabled
it's yet another way the community is
responding to the corona virus pandemic
to ensure those overburdened by economic
struggles are not forgotten
Natacha a guy named al jazeera Chicago
Wellstone Vargas a resident scholar the
American Enterprise Institute is joining
us from Washington DC by Skype thanks
very much indeed for being with us
Donald Trump has been determined that
the economy is going to open as soon as
possible but with so many people out of
work in the United States to an outsider
that seems almost an impossible hope
well yeah I think we're we're definitely
not ready for the economy to reopen
because obviously you know the president
can say that he would like to reopen the
economy and even governors and mayor's
can tell people they were
to reopen the economy but that's not
actually going to work as long as people
are worried that the public health
threat is not under control and people
are not going to go back to restaurants
to bars to sports stadiums unless
they're the the spread of the disease is
under control and widespread testing or
some sort of treatment it's available
and so I think both the president and
other people who support this view that
we can just reopen tomorrow if we if we
if we'd like to are way too optimistic
what are the sections that of business
that are going to be fastest to recover
and what are the ones that are going to
be slowest well I think the sectors that
are going to be slowest are the ones
that rely on reasonably large groups of
people in confined spaces together read
so they include some of the sectors I
just mentioned but also things like
aviation the hotel industry you know
industries like that
I think the sectors that will recover
the fastest include sectors that have
basically continued to function as they
normally do and so that includes you
know your your grocery stores a lot of
tech firms hold you know other services
that do not rely on in-person contacts
and then in addition of course there is
there are parts of the agriculture
manufacturing sectors that have
basically continued as they normally do
the big risk is that there will be a big
drop in demand even when we try to
reopen because we have such high levels
of unemployment and because there is a
risk that a lot of business of
businesses will go into bankruptcy and
so if that happens then suddenly every
industry will be affected very
negatively and so I think that's where
policymakers we try to make a difference
you mentioned the the airline industry
and the tourism industry the hotel
industry as being amongst those slowest
to recover and yet those of course are
the industries that Donald Trump is
specifically keen on trying to bail out
how is that going to affect the American
economy going forward
well we've seen in the in the small
business support program the payroll
protection program we've seen that the
program is in principle restricted to
businesses with under 500 employees but
it is extended precisely in some of
those industries to businesses that have
less the fewer than 500 employees per
establishment and so I think we have
seen some of that influence there I mean
I think otherwise I think the president
will will be very focused on making sure
that the industries in which he has a
personal financial interest receive as
much support as possible from the
federal government I you know I don't
think this administration is married to
very tight ethical rules and so I think
to that extent I think it's good news
for those industries stomm Varga thank
you very much indeed for your time